hey this might be interesting and
informative for you guys as many of you
know
we get
five or so thousand messages a day
across all of our different platforms so
like youtube comments facebook comments
emails twitter replies all these
different things it's impossible to keep
up with all of it and so we we just
can't we just don't okay
every once in a while i like to engage
with someone so like six months ago
um an anti-vaxx emailer
piqued my interest and i said let me
reply and let's see what happens and
then i showed you that exchange and it
was really really wacky and disturbing
so i did it again okay i did it again
the other day
i tweeted about the jobs numbers now one
of the things we talked about on
yesterday's bonus show is
in the midst of everything going on
politically
the jobs numbers which are very good i
mean by every traditional measure
we're basically at full employment now
many of you will say but a lot of people
are still paycheck to paycheck and the
wages aren't good and the jobs are low
quality and people oh 100 i i'm with you
all the way i'm just saying that by
traditional measures which republicans
love to use when it's a republican
president
we are very close to what is considered
full employment and last week there were
extraordinary jobs numbers nearly 700
000 new jobs were created
uh in february we got the february
numbers last week these are very very
good numbers and so i simply tweeted
just to see kind of you know feel around
what's going on
the jobs numbers are very compelling
just really not a very controversial
tweet
and
a guy named andrew responded to me
and said
you mean all the jobs biden destroyed
with his lockdown mania
now
as you can probably imagine there's like
three or four layers on which this is
this is very fallacious
we're talking about job creation
right now jobs we're gaining jobs
um and of course
the job losses that we saw
happened under donald trump and so so
the comment just it doesn't make any
sense but i said hey here's an
opportunity
to try to figure out where this person's
coming from so the first thing was i
wanted to establish does the person even
know what i'm talking about so i wrote
back and i said
did you see the numbers today because
they may not even know that i think it
was 678 000 jobs were created in
february they might just be responding
without having any idea what it is that
i'm talking about and andrew wrote back
and said yeah meaning i did see the jobs
numbers
you can't brag about job creation
when your party caused all the job loss
and again
bragging we're just talking about what
are the jobs numbers is it good to
create jobs and if it is
if you blame who's in the oval office
when jobs are lost
don't they get credit when jobs are
created now you and i hopefully all of
us have a more nuanced understanding of
job creation and we understand that to
some degree
on a delay
job creation or job loss
partially reflects the actions of the
president
but to a significant degree has to do
with global factors broader economic
factors
and and things that have nothing to do
with the president but you've you've got
to be able to play both sides if you
blame a president for job loss you've
got to at least give some equivalent
amount of credit for job creation but
this person is so confused you can't
brag about job creation when your party
caused the job loss so i followed up and
tried to explain
i said quote
almost all the job loss
was in 2020
when donald trump was president what
exactly are you referring to
to which andrew responded
the needless policies that were under
democrats
via their governors and congressmen
they shut the country down needlessly
it's been shown many times lockdown
policies didn't help stop the spread
but hurt
devastated the economy and
so so a couple different things first of
all this experiment was basically a
waste of time and what i mean by that is
each response
moved the discussion to something
different
and it didn't even seem to comprehend
that time moves forward as we understand
it and who was president at different
points in time but it's also wrong on
some pretty basic facts
number one
the economy
uh even by the end i mean listen i'm
glad to admit it because again it has it
has a little to do with the president
but not that much
by the end of trump's presidency the
economy was looking pretty okay
and it continued improving under joe
biden we now have a very shaky stock
market and inflation and we have these
global things but that trend
we were already seeing it under trump
and it continued under biden so even the
claim that everything that was done in
2020 hurt the economy irreversibly it's
just not true
but maybe more importantly
we learned that it doesn't matter even
if i try to engage in good faith and
understand where this person is coming
from
i posted about february jobs numbers
the guy responded and talked about job
losses from 2020
but blamed biden for them even though
trump was president then changed the
conversation to so-called democratic
lockdowns even though it was all under
trump's watch i mean it's red herring
after red herring after straw man after
red herring so
i think what i learned is this is a
waste of my time
and
i don't know because i don't know this
andrew guy i don't know if he's ignorant
and maybe cognitively limited in terms
of being able to engage on the facts
or whether he's arguing in bad faith or
whether he's just trolling me or whether
he was confused or whatever the case may
be i just don't know quite frankly uh
but needless to say
we didn't learn anything from that
conversation and i've probably had my
fill for at least a couple of months but
if i decide to do this again i'll come
i'll come back to you